Angelina when you're playing a character
like this can you shake her off where
did you go home and scare the family and
L what was it like acting opposite such
a terrifying character is she like that
in real life that's my stuff let's start
without no she's definitely not thank
Jeff and real life um but I do think
that no one else could um could have
played Maleficent I mean I there's also
you know for me at least before I had
met Angelina I mean you hear the name
you know Angelina Jolie you know it's
like that name and then I remember
meeting her for the first time and we
were at Pinewood Studios and it was kind
of that day I didn't we were doing
rehearsals and I didn't know that I was
going to specifically meet her then I
didn't know if she was here yet but then
kind of went around like oh she's here
she's here type thing and then I turned
the corner and there she was and she's
you know no horns or anything she is
just normal clothes and but right away
she kind of became flesh you know she
was like the name kind of went away and
it's just like Angelina you know and
people on set or like Angie and you know
it so um and right away she gave me a
giant hug and she said oh we're gonna
have so much fun working together and
she shook my shoulders and I remember
that yeah so it was amazing not not
terrifying but when I did see her in the
costume for the first time I wasn't
scared I was just I was more excited but
you know she had those contact lenses in
and she definitely didn't look like
herself oh that's for sure
um I have to ask my family I thought I
did I thought I came home lovely um you
know the interesting thing about it is
as much as she's she's a she's a villain
and she's dark and she's considered mean
and she was reaiiy was very playful as
her so it is it is a film where it's not
me playing a you know at such a heavy
role that I come home and my children
have to feel the weight of a performance
and this kind of darkness I I came home
very silly and and making it you know
they made my children love Maleficent's
voice so they always make me do it at
home and walk around and so so I think I
think it actually brought out a real the
child in me to be a part of this kind of
film so I I think I was fun